The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
I thought that today what I'd
like to do is to in a sense
clean up a few little things
that were implied by our last
lecture, things that bothered
me a little bit and which I
thought were worthy
of discussing
in more detail today.
You may recall that last time
we discussed the inverse of
differentiation.
And towards the end of the
lecture, we pointed out that
traditionally this operation
was called
the 'indefinite integral'.
Now, you see, two points
bothered me here.
One is why the word integral?
In other words, why not just
'inverse derivative'?
And we're going to talk about
that in more detail later in
the course.
The other part that bothered me
was the inference of what
do you mean by the 'indefinite'
integral, say, as
opposed to the 'definite'
integral?
In essence then, I think that
when you say indefinite
integral, one probably assumes
that there was something
called the definite integral
that exists.
And in order not to prejudice
anything and not to use the
word definite integral in a
context that I don't really
want it in, I have entitled
today's lecture The "Definite"
Indefinite Integral.
And let's see what this
really means now.
Recall that last time we used
the notation that 'D inverse'
'f of x' meant--
and that was what?
This is notation we used, and
we said in the book but this
was denoted by integral ''f of
x' dx', and that this was
called the indefinite
integral.
And what it meant was it was
a name for all function 'G'
whose derivative with respect
to 'x' was 'f'.
And by the mean value theorem,
we also showed what?
That another name for that
set was simply what?
If we knew one function whose
derivative was 'f', call that
capital 'F'.
Then the family capital 'F of
x' plus 'c' was another name
for this set of functions.
And by way of a review, let's
do a typical problem that we
could tackle last time.
Let's see where the word
'indefinite' comes from.
You see, in a sense, the
indefiniteness comes from the
arbitrary constant 'c'.
You see, let's suppose that we
know that 'f prime of x' is 'x
squared', and we now want
to find out what
'f of x' looks like.
You see the inverse of
differentiation again.
We have the derivative.
Well, we know that one function
whose derivative is
'x squared' is '1/3 x cubed'.
Therefore, any other function
whose derivative is 'x
squared' must differ from '1/3
x cubed' by a constant.
Hence, we know that
'f of x' is '1/3 x
cubed' plus a constant.
And it's this 'c' that makes
this thing called the
'indefinite' integral.
You see, at this particular
stage, 'c' could be any
constant whatsoever, and
this would still
be a correct answer.
We have only got a correct
answer up to a family of
functions which differ
only by a constant.
Now, if I specify one piece of
information, which is called
an 'initial condition',
shall we say.
In other words, let's suppose
I specify that when 'x' is
equal to 'x0', 'f of x' is
equal to 'y sub 0', the
subscript 0 here just being
the abbreviation for a
beginning point.
In other words, I now specify
one additional piece of
information.
Well, if I plug this back into
the equation before, I get
that 'f of x0', which is 'y0',
equals '1/3 'x sub 0' cubed
plus c', from which I can
determine that 'c' is equal to
''y0' minus '1/3 x0 cubed''.
Now, notice that 'x0' and
'y0' are given numbers.
Consequently, 'c' here is
a particular number.
And 'c' being a constant, it
means that whatever 'c' is for
one given value of 'x', it
must be that for all.
So now what I can do is replace
the indefinite 'c' by
the definite specific value
''y0' minus '1/3 x0 cubed''
and arrive at the fact that 'f
of x' is that unique function,
the only function that there
is: '1/3 x cubed' plus 'y0'
minus '1/3 x0 cubed'.
In other words, no more
arbitrary constant in here.
What is this function
'f of x'?
Well, it's the function whose
derivative is 'x squared' and
satisfies the condition that
when 'x' is equal to 'x0', 'y'
is equal to 'y0'.
And if you want to see that in
terms of our usual analogy of
resorting to curve plotting,
observe that what we can say
here is what?
The slope is 'x squared'.
Therefore, the curve has the
form 'y' equals '1/3
x cubed plus c'.
We now specify that the
curve passes through
the point (x0, y0).
That helps us determine
that 'c' is 'y0'
minus '1/3 x0 cubed'.
We put that value 'c' back into
our original equation,
and we wind up with 'y' equals
'1/3 x cubed' plus 'y0' minus
'1/3 x0 cubed'.
And what is that particular
curve?
It's the curve that's
characterized by the fact that
its slope at any point (x , y)
is given by 'x squared' and it
passes through the
point (x0, y0).
In other words, notice then that
if we know the slope of a
curve and we know a point on the
curve, in other words, we
know the slope everywhere and we
know a point that the curve
passes through, it shouldn't
seem too surprising that we
can uniquely locate where the
curve is at any time.
And that's exactly
what this says.
We have a unique expression
for this particular curve.
Let's see if we can't generalize
this result.
And instead of talking about 'f
of x' equals 'x squared',
let's consider the following.
Suppose we just generalize it.
We have that we're given that
'dy dx' is 'f of x' and the
domain of 'f' is the closed
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
And now what we'd like to do is
to find out what function
'y' is specifically.
Well, assume that 'g prime'
is any function whose
derivative is 'f'.
And by the way, this is a
pretty big assumption.
In other words, it's one thing
to say let's assume that we
have a function whose
derivative is 'f'.
But for a given 'f', it may not
be quite that simple to
find what 'G' must be.
And we'll talk about
that in more detail
as our course unfolds.
But it's not always that simple
to find a function
which has a given derivative.
We mentioned that in the
last lecture, too.
At any rate, all we're assuming
now though is that by
hook or by crook, somehow or
other, we know a function 'G'
whose derivative is 'f'.
Then therefore, what we conclude
is that since 'G' has
the same derivative as 'y', that
'y' must be 'G of x' plus
a constant.
Now, here's where the word
'initial condition' comes in.
We're starting this problem
at 'x' equals 'a'.
See, 'x' equals 'a'.
What we assume is the curve has
to be someplace when 'x'
equals 'a'.
Let's call that y-coordinate
'y' of 'a'.
In other words, 'y' of 'a' is
equal to 'G of a' plus 'c',
from which we determine that
'c' is equal to 'y of
a' minus 'G of a'.
You see, the only indefinite
thing in here is the 'y of a'.
Because, you see, all we're
saying is we know the
x-coordinate when 'x' is 'a',
and the curve can then pass
through any point whose
x-coordinate is 'a'.
And all we're saying is let's
call the y-coordinate of that
point 'y of a'.
At any rate, knowing what 'c'
is, we now have that 'y of x'
is 'G of x' plus 'y of
a' minus 'G of a'.
Now, in particular, from this,
you see, notice from this, we
can now find out what
'y of b' is.
Namely, we just replace 'x' by
'b', and we get that 'y of b'
is 'G of b' plus 'y of
a' minus 'G of a'.
And again, the only thing
that's indefinite over
here is 'y of a'.
Now, to get rid of the only
indefinite part, it seems
rather clever that maybe all we
should do is subtract 'y of
a' from 'y to b'.
If we do that, we get that 'y of
b' minus 'y of a' is 'G of
b' minus 'G of a'.
Notice that name for 'y of b'
minus 'y of a' is just the
change in 'y' as 'x' moved
from 'a' to 'b'.
In other words, if we know the
derivative of 'y' with respect
to 'x' and we want to find out
how much 'y' changed by as we
moved from 'x' equals 'a' to 'x'
equals 'b', all we have to
do is to compute 'G of b' minus
'G of a' where 'G' is
'a' function whose derivative
is 'f'.
And by the way, that's all this
notation means over here.
This is read this evaluated at
the upper value minus the
value of this evaluated
at the lower value.
In fact, now I suppose the only
problem that's dangling,
as we said, you know, let 'G'
be the function whose
derivative is 'f'.
There are many functions whose
derivative is 'f' once we know
one function whose derivative
is 'f'.
Which function should
we use over here?
And what I intend to show next
is that it really doesn't make
any difference.
That's how definite
this really is.
Namely, let's suppose that 'H'
is any other function whose
derivative is 'f'.
Well, if we use this particular
expression, my
claim is that the change in 'y'
would be a 'H of b' minus
'H of a', the same way
as we did with 'G'.
And the reason for this is that
if 'H' and 'G' have the
same derivative, then they
differ by a constant.
That means that 'H of x' is 'G
of x' plus some constant,
which I denote by 'c1' to
indicate that this is no
longer an arbitrary constant.
What I'm saying is I've picked
a particular 'H'.
I have the 'G' of the
previous problem.
The difference is some
specific constant
which I call 'c1'.
Well, at any rate, I can now
compute 'H to b', which is
just 'G of b' plus 'c1',
'H of a', which is
'G of a' plus 'c1'.
And if I now subtract, I get
'H of b' minus 'H of a' is
equal to 'G of b' minus 'G of
a' because the constant 'c1'
drops out when I form
the subtraction.
In other words, notice that 'G
of b' minus 'G of a' is a
well-determined number
independent of what function
we choose whose derivative
is 'f'.
And to see what this thing
means pictorially, just
observe the following.
Our geometric interpretation
is this.
Let's suppose that we have the
curve 'y' equals 'G of x' on
the closed interval
from 'a' to 'b'.
And what's the property
of 'G'?
It's derivative is 'f'.
And now we look at 'H of x'.
Now, what is 'H of x'?
'H of x' is 'G of x'
plus a constant.
Graphically, what happens
to a curve when
you add on a constant?
You see, adding on a constant
just raises the curve.
In other words, it displaces the
curve parallel to itself
vertically, in other words, with
respect to the y-axis,
that the constant just
lifts the curve.
In other words then, what we're
saying is that when
you're measuring the change in
'y', observe that it really
makes no difference whether
you're talking about this or
whether you're talking
about this.
Because since these two curves
are parallel, you see, the
displacements over these
intervals are the same.
In other words, all we're really
saying, I guess, is
that these two regions
here are congruent.
In fact, it might be wise in
a sense to pick a new axis
either way here, shift this
thing over, and label this the
'delta y' axis.
And what you're really saying
is the arbitrary constant
doesn't really make
any difference.
Because what you've raised the
curve by at this end, you
raised it at this end, and
consequently, the arbitrary
constant drops out in
determining the change in 'y'.
Well, again, this may
still seem abstract.
Let's give a physical
interpretation to what we're
talking about right now.
Let's suppose now that
we have a particle
moving along the x-axis.
A particle is moving
along the x-axis.
We know that its speed at any
time 't' is given by 't
squared', and we know
that the particles
moves for one second.
In other words, the domain
of 't' here is the closed
interval from 0 to 1.
Now, we know that
'v' is 'dx dt'.
Therefore, since '1/3 t cubed'
has its derivative equal to 't
squared', 'x' must be '1/3
t cubed' plus a constant.
And here's where the
word 'initial
condition' comes in again.
We're starting this problem
when 't' equals 0.
When 't' equals 0, the particle
has to be someplace.
Let's say it's at 'x'
equals 'x sub 0'.
That's 'x of 0', you see.
And if we do this, notice
that when 't' is 0,
'x' is 'x sub 0'.
That says that 'c'
is 'x sub 0'.
Replacing 'c' by 'x sub 0', we
find that the particle moves
according to the rule
'x' equals '1/3 t
cubed' plus 'x sub 0'.
Now, we can find out where the
particle is when 't' equals 1.
When 't' equals 1, 'x'
is '1/3 plus 'x0''.
We know that when the particle
started at 't' equals 0, 'x'
of 0 was 'x sub 0'.
And therefore, the change in
'x', in other words, 'x'
evaluated when 't' equals '1
minus x' evaluated when 't'
equals 0 is simply what? '1/3
plus 'x0' minus 'x0'', or 1/3.
In other words, in this
particular problem, if we
choose as our unit, say, feet
and seconds, if a particle
moves for 1 second according to
the rule that speed in feet
per second is the square of the
time, in 1 second it has
been displaced by a distance
of 1/3 of a foot.
And if I want to draw that for
you, let me show you what's
happening over here.
What we're saying is
here is a particle
moving along the x-axis.
when we start this problem
at time 't' equals 0, the
particle is at some point
'x' equals 'x0'.
We observe that the particle
is moving because of the
velocity 't squared', and that
means it's always moving from
left to right.
And what we find is that when
the time is 1, the particle is
now at 'x0 + 1/3'.
In other words, in this 1
second, the particle has moved
1/3 of a foot.
By the way, to make a little
interesting aside while we're
here, and we'll come back to
this in more detail also into
future lectures, notice that
since 'v' equals 't squared',
when 't' is 0, the
velocity is 0.
And when 't' is 1, since 't
squared' is then 1, the
velocity is 1.
Notice that the particle starts
with 0 velocity, ends
up with a velocity of 1, but the
average velocity is not a
half a foot per second.
In other words, notice that the
particle traveled a total
distance of 1/3 of a
foot in 1 second.
In other words, the average
speed was just 1/3 of a foot
per second.
And you see, notice that in this
particular problem, since
'v' is equal to 't
squared', the
acceleration is not a constant.
The acceleration is '2t'.
It's a variable.
Notice, for example, that the
time is approximately 7/10 of
a second before the particle
would move a half a foot.
See, in other words, notice that
the time has to be 7/10
of a second before the
velocity is 1/2.
Namely, when you square
0.7, you get 0.49.
And notice again the
nonlinearity of this, which,
as I say, we'll come back to
later, but I thought it was
worth mentioning in
passing over here.
At any rate, let's generalize
this velocity problem because
I think it's much easier to
think in terms of distance,
rate, and time than in terms
of slopes of curves.
But let's just take
a look here.
The generalization is this.
Let's oppose that we
have a particle
moving along the x-axis.
Its speed at any time is given
by 'v' equals 'f of t', and
the time interval is from 't'
equals 'a' to 't' equals 'b'.
We assume that capital 'G' is
any function whose derivative
is 'f', and we then can conclude
that therefore 'x'
must be 'G of t' plus
a constant.
We also say OK, initially
that's what?
Not necessarily 0.
Initially is when we
start the problem.
When 't' equals 'a', 'x of
a' is 'G of a' plus 'c'.
'x of t', therefore,
is 'G of t'.
Notice that 'c' is 'x of a'
minus 'G of a', so 'x of t' is
'G of t' plus 'x of
a' minus 'G of a'.
From this, just replacing 't'
by 'b', I find that 'x of b'
is 'G of b' plus 'x of
a' minus 'G of a'.
Again, this is the only
indefinite part here.
Notice, by the way, that this
is mimicking what I did
earlier for 'dy dx', but I
wanted to go through this one
more time in terms of a more
tangible physical example.
At any rate, if I now subtract
'x of a' from this result, I
wind up with that 'x of b' minus
'x of a' is 'G of b'
minus 'G of a'.
In other words, the change in
'x' on this time interval from
'a' to 'b' is determined just
by evaluating 'G of b' minus
'G of a' where 'G'
is any function
whose derivative changes.
See, a rather easy
way of evaluating
this particular thing.
Now, again I should point out
as an interesting physical
aside that this 'delta x' is
a displacement, not a total
distance, and I'll explain
what that means
in terms of an example.
You see, let's observe that in
the problem that I did over
here, in this particular problem
over here, notice that
the velocity was always
positive.
In given problems, the velocity
can oscillate between
positive and negative, meaning
in terms of moving along the
x-axis, the particle
can sometimes move
from left to right.
Other times, it can from
right to left.
But at any rate, what I want
to point out is that the
change in 'x' is a displacement,
a net change.
Let me give you an example.
Let's suppose again
that a particle is
moving along the x-axis.
Now its speed 'v' is given
by 't - 1' where 't' is
between 0 and 2.
Now, the function I'm looking
for, 'x', must differ from a
constant by a constant from any
function whose derivative
is 't - 1'.
In particular, one function
whose derivative is 't - 1' is
'1/2 t squared' minus 't'.
So whatever 'x' is, it
must have what form?
It's '1/2 t squared' minus
't' plus a constant.
Now, I want to compute 'x'
evaluated when 't' is 2, 'x'
evaluated when 't' is 0, and
take this difference because
that will be the change in
'x', you see, as 't'
goes from 0 to 2.
Well, at any rate, you see 'x of
2', just putting 2 in here,
gives me 1/2 of 4, which
is 2, minus 2 plus
'c', which is 'c'.
'x of 0' is 'c', and therefore,
'x of 2' minus 'x
of 0' is 0.
Or written more symbolically,
'delta x' as 't' goes
from 0 to 2 is 0.
In other words, there
is no change in 'x'.
Now, obviously, we don't mean
the particle didn't
move in this case.
For no motion, the velocity
should be 0, but the velocity
is 't - 1'.
Let's see what really happened
in this particular problem.
To do this, I have drawn some
separate graphs over here.
The first one shows 'v'
in terms of 't'.
And what this shows is what?
That when 't' is between 0
and 1, 'v' is negative.
Now, there's nothing imaginary,
again recall, about
a negative velocity.
Remember, that since the
particle is moving along the
x-axis and the positive sense of
the x-axis is from left to
right, a negative velocity means
that the particle is
just moving from
right to left.
So what this says is the
particle was moving from right
to left for the first second
and then from left to right
for the second second.
Also, if we now want to plot the
distance versus the time,
you see, what we see is that
'x' is equal to '1/2 t
squared' minus 't'.
That's this particular shape.
And the plus 'x sub 0' is
our initial condition.
In other words, this tells us
lookit, when we started this
problem at 't' equals 0, the
particle was positioned at 'x'
equals 'x sub 0'.
And notice what this
thing seems to say.
This seems to say that what?
You started here.
Then for the first second, the
displacement was decreasing.
That means you were moving in
the negative direction.
And then you reached a certain
peak here, and when you got
down to this particular point,
you started to come back.
And at the end of the second
second, your displacement was
exactly what it was when
you first started here.
And by the way, let me again
mention, this is not the graph
of how the particle moved.
The particle is moving
horizontally along the x-axis.
This graph is just how the
displacement looks as a
function of time.
In fact, by the way, to see how
we can eliminate the 'x
sub 0' here, I have
drawn one more.
You'll notice that in our
recipe, we said let's compute
'1/2 t squared' minus 't'
as 't' goes from 0 to 2.
That was the special case where
I replaced the x-axis by
the 'delta x' axis.
In other words, the curve 'x'
equals '1/2 t squared' minus
't' would be this curve here.
In other words, when
't' is 0, 'x' is 0.
This says what?
The change in 'x' when you start
the problem is 0 because
the particle hasn't moved yet.
And this says what?
The particle moves, reaches
a minimum value
when 't' equals 1.
And when 't' equals 1, 'x'
equals minus 1/2, and then
comes back to 0 when
't' equals 2.
In other words, physically what
happened here is the following.
We started this problem
at 't' equals 0.
At 't' equals 0, the particle
had a certain displacement, a
certain initial position which
we'll call 'x sub 0'.
And what happened in this
problem is that for the first
second, the particle moved
from right to left.
And when 't' was equal to 1,
the particle was at the
position 'x sub 0' minus 1/2,
which is just another way of
saying it was 1/2 of a unit, or
in this case, 1/2 a foot to
the left of its starting
point.
Then during the next second,
the velocity is positive.
The particle doubles back,
returns to the point 'x0' when
't' equals 2, so that the
displacement, meaning the net
change in position during the
time interval of this problem,
the net distance
traveled is 0.
It started and finished
at the same point.
On the other hand, the total
distance traveled is 1/2 a
foot in this direction, 1/2 a
foot in this direction, so
therefore, a total of 1 foot.
Well, you see, I thought this
was a worthwhile discussion to
have on distance,
rate, and time.
But I also thought another thing
was rather important.
Did you notice that except for
my mentioning at the beginning
of our lesson that the inverse
derivative is called the
indefinite integral, that the
so-called integral sign has
never appeared in anything
that I've done.
In other words, to emphasize
what I was talking about in
the last lecture, observe that
I could get by wonderfully
without ever having heard of
an integral sign, without
having heard of the phrase
indefinite integral.
At any rate, though, let me ask
the following query, so to
speak, to sort of lead into
a summation point of view.
Once we invent the notation
integral ''f of x' dx' to
denote the set of all functions
'G' whose derivative
is 'f', why not invent a new
symbol, namely, what?
We'll still use this integral
sign, but now put that lower
and upper bound on this thing.
We'll call this the definite
integral ''f of x' dx', or the
definite indefinite integral--
I put these limits
on, 'a' to 'b'--
to denote 'G of b' minus 'G of
a' where 'G prime' is any
function whose derivative
is 'f'.
In other words, to put this in
still another perspective,
remember the 'G' was a member
of the family described by
interval ''f of x' dx'.
To indicate that I'm going to
compute 'G of b', why not put
a 'b' on top of this
integral sign?
And then to indicate that I'm
going to subtract from that 'G
of a', why not denote 'G of a'
by the same integral sign with
an a underneath it?
And then symbolically, I can
think of 'G of b' minus 'G of
a' as being this expression
here, which I will then
abbreviate as--
you see, in other words, I'll
take this thing and say OK,
this is now an abbreviation
for what we have here.
In other words, that when you
see this thing, which we'll
call the definite indefinite
integral, ''f of x' dx' from
'a' to 'b', this is just an
abbreviation for what?
'G of x', 'G of b' minus 'G of
a' where 'G' is a function
whose derivative is 'f'.
And with this in mind
now, I can summarize
our lecture as follows.
Suppose I know that 'dy dx' is
'f of x', where 'x' is defined
on the closed interval
from 'a' to 'b'.
Then the change in 'y' on this
interval, in other words, the
change in 'y' as 'x' goes from
'a' to 'b' is given by the
symbol integral 'a' to 'b' ''f
of x' dx' where this symbol is
defined to be 'G of x' evaluated
between 'x' equals
'a' and 'x' equals 'b', meaning
'G of b' minus 'G of
a', where 'G' is any function
whose derivative is 'f'.
Notice again then, in closing,
that this particular symbol
here, as far as I'm concerned,
is artificial.
I don't really need it.
And whereas it might have been
unfortunate to invent the
phrase indefinite integral, it
might be even more unfortunate
to have two words sounding
so much alike that
are completely different.
In other words, notice that when
I write the integral sign
from 'a' to 'b' ''f of x'
dx', what this thing
denotes is a number.
It's a change in 'y'.
Without the two numbers here,
'a' and 'b', this denotes a
set of functions, namely, all
functions whose derivative
with respect to 'x'
is 'f of x'.
Well, anyway, I hope that this
straightens out, if nothing
more, the difference between
the words definite and
indefinite.
And we shall return to
the subject called--
or turn to the subject called
integral calculus and bring
this up in more detail
from a different
context in a little while.
In the meantime, we'll have
a little sojourn into the
circular functions and revisit
trigonometry for a few days
while we allow this idea
here to set more
firmly in your mind.
So until next time, goodbye.
Funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.